so you watch these tragedies unfold in
slow motion life around you degrade year
by year and you think well i guess
that's just the way it is now and then
occasionally someone steps forward and
says no it doesn't have to be this way
you could actually fix this and it's not
that complicated and that's one of the
messages that sheriff alex villanueva
has been telling the rest of us here in
los angeles he joins us we're happy that
he is on the fox lot in l.a chef thanks
so much for coming on oh thank you so i
know this is a everything's complicated
this is a complicated place but i don't
think it's complicated to say the
actions of one prosecutor really have
changed life here definitely in his
first year in office 2021 his first full
year he rejected over 12 200 cases for
my agency alone and multiply that by two
and that's all the other local police
departments in the lapd so his efforts
is really almost nullifying the
legislative intent in sacramento where
misdemeanor crimes are seldom prosecuted
if he believes is attached to
homelessness or drug abuse they're not
going to touch them so obviously that's
fostering a climate where homelessness
drug abuse is just spiraling out of
control and you're seeing with your own
eyes
well you certainly are and you know if
you love la anyone who spent a lot of
time in la there's so much to love it
really is a great city
and it's gotten worse and there's kind
of no arguing that
he's the prosecutor you're the sheriff
there should be a relationship between
the two of you how have you brought this
to his attention can you talk to him
well i've had one conversation with him
that was his first week in office where
we had an issue of mutual concern on a
kate one particular case but his
predecessor we met every three months i
met her in her office she met me in my
office we shared concerns exactly what
you're saying we did well this gentleman
unless you come from the public
defenders
office
you were a black lives matter activist
those are about the only people he's
speaking to everyone else just doesn't
exist in his world
just one question since you live here
and run a big agency here is there huge
public support for his policies do you
think no not at all i'm seeing a lot of
support from victims you know victims
matter they should be at the forefront
of everything all of the criminal
justice system is supposed to do now
it's all crim offender specific or
offender centric everything is about
reducing harm not to victims of crime
reducing harm of incarceration for those
who commit crime and that is astonishing
leap of logic that not just george
gascon but the board of supervisors has
embraced the very same idea they call it
care first jail last which has been an
absolute failure here in la county man i
hope you take this place over i really
do use the democratic process just to
restore moderate sensibility to the way
it's run i really hope that
sure thank you you got it subscribe to
the fox news youtube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from tucker carlson tonight